okay I'm playing with the black thesis
this game is played in a crucial last
round of the Olympia Olympia it is one
of the biggest tournaments every two
years and this was the last run of the
Olympiad my first time playing for the
US team in 2006 and it's a match against
Norway and mock miss Carson was playing
in this match he was playing on the
board one against Kamsky their game
ended in a draw and we had to win the
other three boards we were favourites
that was our only chance to win the rest
of the three boards to win three and
half half to try to win a medal and
eventually that happened and my game was
the last game to finish of the match we
were winning two and a half half and
after my win the US team won the bronze
medal in that tournament you know it was
really the big big result for us I'm
playing against a grandmaster 2,500
player his last name is Lee and he
played a 4e six it's not surprised
because I've been playing the French
defense for so many years so we see the
French defense opening cage now he
played d4 d5 any played f5 and everybody
familiar do you know this line what he
is playing here what is it called
advanced okay this the advanced there
are four main lines why can try to play
here he can play advanced he can play
exchange he can play Knight c3 he can
play in 92 you can play this four
different lines but he played the e5 so
we have the advanced now if you if you
don't attack on the default right away
then white is going to be simply better
because he has a strong power only $5
controlling squares so you have to try
to attack the center so c5 c3 and now I
play the move knight c6
activating the night and putting
pressure Knight f3 and the most popular
move in this position is the move Queen
b6 which you know I normally play but in
this game I didn't want to play
something that he would definitely
prepare against me because I played this
all the time so I wanted to play this
idea Bishop d7 first I'm not putting my
queen on b6 yet I want to play a rook c8
and wait a little bit that's what I'm
trying to do now I plays Bishop d3 and
rook c8 after a cleric c8 I already have
a threat a positional threat here to win
his light square Bishop do you see it do
you see what I'm trying to do here
yes yeah so for example if he castles I
will take on d4 he cannot take back with
the Knight e5 pawn is hanging so he has
to take back with a pawn and then then I
simply play Knight before attacking the
light square bishop the bishop cannot
move from d3 because if he goes back to
eat you after night c2 he is losing the
rook okay so he will rook to lose the
rook on a1 that's why he cannot do that
so that's why he took on c5 he gives
away the center by taking but at least
he avoided this idea of C takes d4 now I
play Bishop takes c5 and castle now what
is the move in this position this is a
very interesting move I think I played
here it's not an easy position because
if white manages to get a knight on the
23 and you have a good outpost for the
night and his bishops are very active
and this Punk only if I could be quite
annoying here because it's guarding many
squares and makes my pieces clumped and
pass it so now what can you do here
which hope
yeah I mean a five you could play but he
plays a four for example a five will be
probably made by a four and then he will
still do that idea so it's a it's a
deeper deeper idea here I mean I'm not
saying this is just the best move in
this position but it's quite interesting
idea here so think about it and let me
know if you see something that will help
me improve my position here and you have
to look at the position which piece is
the best piece in this position for
white the minor piece Knight is okay the
bishop Anitra's is the best minor piece
very active also here so what I like to
do I like to make sure this bishop is
not very active so what can you do to
liyan
f5 absolutely now he has two options now
take on poisson or not to take because
if it hip-hip 895 him he made inaccurate
move here but for example if he takes on
poisson then let's look at the
development how many pieces you see now
that I have developed one three four
five I have five pieces developed in
next move I'm going to cancel and I will
be suddenly I have a very nice lead in
development here okay so that's why I
played f5 and if it doesn't take then
his bishop is not as active anymore
because it will be blocked by the pawn
on f5 okay so that's why I really like
this move f5 here it's a not easy move
to play but I had a similar idea that
I've done before in one of my games so I
was familiar with it so f5 now he should
have played you know he probably should
have played here 9b d2 and play
something in IBD 297 93 we should be six
then I cancel then I put my knight on g6
it's a it's a comfortable position
position for blackish I'm naturally
black it's better here but at least is I
think at least
Kohi so he played 95 here a very
aggressive move but look at his
development see the pieces are not
developed so he's moving the same piece
twice playing an active move and first
of all do you see what he is trying to
do here yes
well Queen h5 in some point yes he wants
to do that too but I have g6 right away
yeah he wants to play Bishop f5 takes c6
some Queen d5 ideas so very tactical
he's trying to try very tactical here
try to open up the position now what
should I do here but what is the problem
with this move
do you see it upon of course he pond and
I take it but he didn't just blonde at
the pond he has an idea behind it and
now he sacrifices if I kick he's gonna
go rook e1 and he's gonna pin so I don't
want to take it because he plays rook e1
and I'm gonna lose my knight and my
position looks very loose d5 pawn at
five
it's not gonna be that good now black to
play now here can you find the best move
here
Brook what
Oh Roxy 6r rookie one it's going to
start pressuring on efile no excellent
Queen f6 developing another piece and
gaining a crucial temple it's very
important that you do that you can try
to gain as much lead as possible in the
opening I'm not worried about losing h7
pawn here or anything like that
development is more important here so
Queen f6 combining developing a piece
and defending against his stretch of
only six now he needs to move his bishop
so he goes bishop c2 now what is the
next move here
absolutely continue developing say on
the second move again I'm not worrying
about losing h7 pony because this
actually will open up the h5 for my rook
this will be very dangerous for me and
almost all of my pieces developed that's
fine i g5 was a bad move basically he
has twice moved the same piece twice and
here we see a grandmaster he's a
grandmaster from norway in a crucial
match at olympia last round he is not
following the principles and he's gonna
get into big trouble right away
he moved his knight twice right Knight
f3 Knight g5 now he moved his Bishop
twice if you do that in the opening this
is gonna be the scenario your pieces are
not gonna be developed and look at my
pieces every piece almost developed here
and I'm ready to attack now after I
castle so it goes king h1 he wants to
play f4 he couldn't play a4 before
because the bishop was pinning here but
now he's threatening to play a 4 now
what should I do
obviously I would like to caster but I
can't at this point because my 8 7 pawn
is hanging h6 attacking the knight now
he doesn't have a choice now look at
this gaining another tempo now he moved
the night at 3 times and look at his 90s
awkward on the side of the board and I'm
controlling the center so I Castle if
you had to evaluate this position here
let's say you just try to evaluate here
what would be the evaluation here it's
pretty clear the block is better but is
it slightly better is it a big advantage
it's not winning yet but it's between
those two what will be your assessment
here slightly better or big advantage
for black big advantage
absolutely the wall night is very badly
placed on h3 yes yes Julian yeah
class point five well I think that's
still slightly yeah but but okay anybody
else wants to give us the assessment
what do you think here is it slightly
better or this is the big advantage here
point a that's already close to big
advantage in my opinion it's a big
advantage here because first of all it's
very easy for me to play because I have
all my pieces developed and it's more
difficult for him because he still needs
to figure out where to develop the
pieces and it's not like he has a
concrete idea okay I put this piece here
it still needs time he now he puts the
night on d2 then he no need to move the
night again the night is not really
developed on the two that well so
there's a problem but I need a plan here
so I need to find a good plan here to
your pieces look good but if you don't
do anything for next couple of moves
he's gonna develop he's gonna catch up
so you need a plan here what would be
the idea here for black
he wants to play a four we know that
that's why he moved his King to h1
well g5 it's a risky move it's like you
playing into f4 you know G if I'll
actually he will play a four anyway so
it's not like it's you really stopped f4
what would be a good time
aha that's a good idea but which one
excellent excellent job yes so he played
f4 it was his MO actually sorry I
cancelled f4 and it's obvious I have to
move this Knight here so 9 goes on g6
first of all when you place Queen d3
then there's no more diagonal letter
threats there you know Queen h7 ideas so
and if I go here what is my next move
what is the next move here that I have
to play because if I let him put his
knight on f3 then he's back in the game
this was 95 9 f3 maybe maybe it's still
better for me but not so much yes you
have to play e5 here ok and now I'm
ready to take this night away on h3 and
now I'm opening up position when you
have the lead in development this is
what you need to do you need to open the
position because he still needs to
develop these pieces so he still has
problems and you'll see in this game in
there he never really got the chance to
develop his pieces
he was always behind so now my opponent
sees that he is in big trouble here
because if he takes only 5 I just take
tack yeah you can gain the tempo here
but after I go here it's big trouble
taking on h3
and then I have five ideas I have also
so it's a very very difficult position
for him so he decided to play a fancy
move 94 if he plays normal he's way
behind so he wants to get tactical ideas
here see if he can complicate the
Mayoress and maybe defend now working my
bishop and a queen here so I believe I
don't have much choice here I cannot
move my Queen to a good square he'll
take the bishop so I have to take and
now he takes but he's still behind
development look and a bishop so what do
you do now this move is very important
to play now because he wants to take
your pawn on e4 so what can you do
yes excellent
pushing the pawn now he goes here
f5 attacking the knight do I have to
worry about that no I push it again he's
gonna go rook e1
yes
Queen a6 rookie one nice move but they
have a follow up to and then I just take
your pawn bishop e3 and then looks like
Roxi dat I think he just takes it takes
on b7
a bishop takes a fire no no no no sorry
bishop takes III I just connect my rooks
and then I take on a five yeah this
takes your ambition or exceed e8 takes
context
oh no no this is very good move needed
here yes
absolutely neither for activating the
night he takes what else to do here you
cannot leave the night there I take and
now he takes down upon but most
important thing this pieces are not
coming out this Bishop if the bishop
cannot come out and the rook is gonna be
stuck so what do you do yes push
threatening to Queen now what is he
gonna do
by the way he cannot play Bishop d2 now
because we have rook F d8 and we pick up
the bishop okay so if it goes Bishop d2
we just go here and we take it okay so
it goes Queen d2 only move to defend
because if you place here do you see why
this move loses
that's probably winning but they have
something simpler no absolutely rook e8
threatening to when you can play this
move but take Queen f1 yeah so he played
Queen d2 now
now threatening to play Yvonne Quinn so
again he cannot play rookie for because
if you prefer before you just take and
Quinn have one mate okay so that's
doesn't work so he has to play cleanly
one and now what to do here it looks
like a very big advantage for black but
you still need to find a way to break
through so you need to come up with that
plan here how to win this position
you like g5 you have been calling that
g5 know a couple of times g5 you can
even take maybe you know give up that
peace win another pawn only two and then
here's a good amount of puns I know he
could have to be puns so I mean it's not
bad
you should disable is the idea everybody
wants to play g5 well okay maybe it's
not bad but I have something more
concrete here
see what I like to do is I like to open
the F file because then my rook is
actually playing on f8 so I want to try
to open up that F file how can I try to
do that of course the most obvious is to
take but the problem he takes and at the
end of the line I just lose my phone and
I cannot do anything my rook is not
placed well here I cannot do any
background ideas and then he'll develop
his Bishop do what Knight d5 rook f3
let's say Knight g6 yes absolutely 96
attacking the rook what is he gonna do
now he only has one move to play
otherwise he's losing immediately rook
f3 his his only move because if he takes
what is the winning move
so I need okay Julian excellent
attacking the Queen Queen moves we
promote upon into a queen and if he
takes with the rook we take and we
checkmate got it that's the idea okay so
it was rook F 3 and now yeah this
sequence is my favorite idea of the game
actually because after that it's already
pretty simple winner
excellent very nice Alex night h4 again
second move in a row he cannot take the
night if he moves it this is what's
gonna happen if you don't develop your
pieces they're not gonna help you so
again he cannot take it and again he has
only one move he can play here
rook f4 anywhere he goes you see the
winning move instantly Bishop f2
excellent yes all right now no no no
well I don't want because you know we
need to win a medal this is the medal
game you know last round yeah well yeah
I didn't repeat I just once I saw this
move it wasn't so if this move is not so
easy to see but once you find this move
you're just winning
but again in order to win I need to take
the spot away from f5 then my rook is in
a game then I will win the game but I
can't take again here because he will
exchange everything and I lose my pawn
g5 well g5 I think you could probably
win a piece here but takes I'm not sure
if this is that clear I mean you're
probably better but I have three pawns
you know so it's not so clear I have
enough maybe enough compensation here
it's a very nice move it's always nice
in a complex position like this to find
time to play a move like that well it
seems like there's no way you don't have
time for any moves like they're
improving the position you think it's so
concrete you know yes rook cd8 but I'm
gonna help us with our plan
okay look cd8 might be winning also I'm
not sure I understand but it might be
winning but what move I play here huh
yes bish before not so clear see in a
messy positions like this you always
have to just sit down and calculate you
need to have time this is where you need
to spend your time here to calculate a
clear-cut line here that you played this
move then you take this and you win the
game so and again I want to make sure I
don't lose my e to pawn if I'm gonna win
a piece but lose upon and lose my a to
pond and he's gonna have some
compensation okay I don't want him to
have compensation excellent he's got no
moves he has two pieces attacking the
knight but none of them can really take
it if he takes with a queen you want
Queen and if he takes here's
look at this move again he cannot take
because of e2 so I was pretty confident
here that I'm gonna win this game now
after this move and at least we have a
chance to win a medal now yeah he plays
Bishop d2 and okay trying to develop
trying to do something Knight xl5
I mean he really doesn't have many moves
here and I'm just ready to move my night
and there will be many threats on earth
file here he goes rookie for now
attacking my queen what to do if I move
my queen he just takes the pawn only to
and he is very happy
Margie treats context
yeah that if I take take yeah that might
be good too
I didn't play 93 actually my g3 tax
reform King h2 might be working to a 93
but a move in the game no chance may be
complete domination here okay after this
move you see a board where just black is
just completely dominating and no
counter play absolutely no counter play
here
well yeah that move was suggested it's
probably winning also it's probably
winning too but I I found some of the
lines not as clear you know I'm not so
clear you know but the move in a game
it's clear that it's pretty much over
now take the rook of course see you
don't have to think too much about this
one because look at this look at the
board complete domination look at the
screen here no squares to go to Bishop
cannot go anywhere
Luke barely has any squares to go to
King is in trouble can't really do
anything now he plays here and now what
do you do here
now here I actually didn't play the best
move here I should have just played a
move after which I'm just up a piece and
just like you know a couple of more
moves I'll be out the piece so don't
find my move now find the best mode the
eight is an idea no g5 najiba guys but
my look is hanging yeah looking for is
probably all this moves are winning but
how about how about this move 93 give
him that look we don't need it
he takes it check and checkmate so it's
not gonna take it
he takes check if he goes back we go you
won Queen he has to take it okay this
would have just probably forced the
resignation here there's nothing we can
do here you have to resign because you
down a piece for a pawn so so I didn't
do that I wasn't as experienced at that
time this was cleaned in 2006 and I was
too young I think still thinking about
fancy fancy ideas so I go here now idea
is 93 check and then rook h5 mate and
now he played Bishop e1
and here here again I couldn't go 93 and
I'm just winning easily but again I had
this you know I didn't play very well
here actually I paid 93 because I
thought I could finish this game but
especially in this kind of tournaments
in the situations you don't play like a
fancy you played the straightforward way
you know I should have just play 93
earlier or now so I tell you what I miss
I thought this is actually a nice line
because if he just he cannot take with a
pawn as we discussed this mate so he has
to take and I thought I just go huge and
this is just a nice finish resign and I
only calculated the line that where he
goes h3 I go check he goes here I take
take I go here and I thought wow this is
a great line yeah and I go Bishop EFT
when I win the game that's it but what I
were I overlooked I overlooked the idea
that he can play here h4 and this gives
his King
h3 squared this was a complete shock for
me during the game but another reason
about I'm showing you this of course I
could have won easily with 93 but it
shows that you still have to make that
adjustment here after you miss like an
obvious win you don't just think oh you
know I ruin the game let's just take a
draw you know no you still have to try
to you know fight back and now win a
better endgame I don't remember actually
yeah but I never let it go to I never
let my advantage like there was never a
doubt that I would win the game but now
it's technical okay but I'm glad I show
a good technique to convert to sign
again so I check he goes here I take the
problem is now if I go here that same
line that I showed you when I go check
he's got this move and now he will win
my poem might be in trouble here so
of course I was disappointed that I just
kind of instead of just game one already
just you know celebrated now I have to
still win the one game but it's okay
Luke d8 good move threatening to go rook
d1 so he is forced to play the move rook
e1 he's got no choice
rook belongs where yes Luke t2 now I
want to start winning some palms e to
pun is very very strong even equal
material here we cannot really do
anything so he plays B for now
no spell to go Bishop e7 because I want
to keep my eye on h4 and I want to play
Bishop f6 next and try to win upon most
likely he's gonna win my pawn I'm not
gonna be able to promote this pawn but I
want to win upon before that happens
when 2 pounds so when he wins my pan
I'll have extra pawn here now I'm
threatening to take the pawn on a 2 so
he goes kim jiwon the reason he didn't
defend this with a 4 because then might
be in bigger trouble after this move
then I take this pot if he doesn't want
to lose it then I can go even here then
try to move this rook from here so so he
played King g1 he wants to just win the
pan as soon as possible
Bishop f6 King f2 I pick up the a to
pawn he takes bishop c3 now in this this
endgame is winning for black because
it's the same color bishop and I have
enough pants on the King side so I will
try to create a passed pawn on the Kings
side and use that part as a decoy to
make his scheme to go that way to win it
and then my king will go after the other
2 pounds and win the game so now he has
to play b5 rapid King f7 King Bishop f2
attacking the pawn and now I played a 5
I could have also played a 6 here I
thought it didn't really matter because
he has to take on person anyway but he
didn't take on person if he takes again
it should be pretty easy win for black
here I just take back so he goes King
here
attacking my Bishop Bishop belongs we're
in the same game where
well we should before now it goes here
King e6 first I stopped his scheme now
it's kinky not getting anywhere he goes
G for now I'm gonna push a phone right
by my bishop is on the way so drop back
Bishop e7 he goes here push now he goes
here now calculate can you calculate a
King and pawn endgame Kenya excellent
Bishop f6 if it doesn't take then my
king is gonna just come here and start
picking up those pawns you know if he
doesn't trade the bishop my King has a
entry point so he takes what is the best
way to take it don't rush King f7 King
before
take one of course now he goes came
before now
takes Julian you you keep on giving
chances here I already give a chance
once in this game no more I don't I
don't want my coach and team have heart
attack in huh
now it's a final touch here the final
touch here is fix him b6 no entry points
for the King so he has to take back now
which one is important to win first
which part we want to win so he has no
chance
well you tried all of them King here he
goes here look at this he cannot keep
his pawn on b5 so he goes here you have
f2 x g5 so again if he goes king a4 I go
King c4 he goes here he'll only chance
now he goes here trying to get in what
do you do now
correct he goes King before he goes
after my pawn and now calculate you
could go King to six what else you can
do push push push and he resign because
if he plays g5 I can take he coins and
yes I have the queen bee - so after this
I want he resigned and I had no idea
because going into this round we were
like seventh on the standings before the
last round so I had no idea that there
was some miracle results had to happen
like Russia would need to lose to Israel
and like some other things really out of
our reach you know we didn't really
control but they everything happened to
our a fever and as soon as I want this
now our team captain Jon Donson already
calculated everything that we actually
win the bronze we tie with Israel but we
win on a better tie break so anyway
after this win we won the bronze medal
at the 2006 Olympiad in Turin so the
important game one of the most important
games I think I've won because it was
important for him for the team and for
me also so again they're a very
important game here
Norway yeah Lee yeah occasionally it
still yeah okay great yang Carlson
played also this was you know he was
very young at that time but he drew the
only guy who drew was Coulson
he drew against Kamsky as as black
actually at Olympia but we want the
other three boards